[Music]
you'll princess may be super charming is
back yeah it's happening this is
recording now and we'll be recording the
whole time house law was a convicted
felon he is also an informant for the
Federal Bureau of Investigation we have
a buyer don't take everything you got
got him you cop these guys find out
you're a cop you're dead man you
understand I'm gonna give you one cheese
and I'm gonna give it to you in a few
seconds no this is bad business sterzick
tells me that the cop was pointing the
gun in your face you know the price of
your life to Wojtek how much is your
life or you'll break your parole get
back to prison anyone can get drugs
inside it's you know we go along with
the generals plan evidence of fentanyl
being methodically distributed inside a
state prison berries for general for
good and if that happens
you're a free man go back inside
I'll never get out I'm hit investigating
a death of somebody very closely we
can't have this Detective find out that
an FBI informant was present during the
murder of one of his own you want to
pitch your field office against the
biggest Police Department in the world
we love us a good fight what are you
thinking
burnin he has a family
we looked him in the eyes we made him
guarantees I don't have kids and I'd
suffer too much something happen to me
please don't scare I'm doing everything
I can
thomna hang there and I just put a tight
noose around your neck I'm not a
mattress this ends now
surprise
[Music]
[Music]
you